desde que comenzó la guerra en este
restaurante ruso han caído las reservas
más de un 60% por eso vlada su
propietaria quiere dejar claro que aquí
abren cada día pero el mensaje más
importante sin duda está en la puerta
por eso queremos estar seguros que la
gente que viene a comer aquí entiende
que su dinero no va a apoyar putin o su
régimen
en el interior las mesas están vacías o
sólo tienen cinco reservas algo inusual
en este emblemático negocio de manhattan
donde hasta ahora era casi imposible
conseguir una mesa y han dejado de venir
la gente está cancelando las reservas
que hicieron antes de la guerra los
diversos ironías de la vida hablada
nació en san petesburgo su hijo nicolás
es americano y el patriarca de la
familia ucraniano de la portuaria odessa
ahora bajo amenaza rusa solo porque este
es un establecimiento ruso no significa
que le damos a putin dinero pero no todo
el mundo lo ve igual y ellos se están
cargando la culpa de una guerra que no
apoyan
me he levantado con una llamada
telefónica diciendo en ruso eres ruso y
palabras que no puedo decir al aire
cosas como ojalá te mueras nací y siendo
judío que te llamen así no tiene sentido
así es
los negocios rusos de la gran manzana
cada vez se sienten más presionados
sobre todo después de que joe biden
prohibió la entrada a este país donde
productos estrellas rusos como los
diamantes el pescado el marisco el
caviar y el vodka
oportunidad perfecta para la entrada de
otras marcas nos cuenta este
distribuidor de licores
volví bolis bein
leonard filis el propietario de la
licorería tiene familia en ucrania por
eso aquí el alcohol ruso recoge fondos
para la causa ucraniana world town y
vamos a donar una parte de las ventas a
una iglesia ucraniana oa una
organización que apoye la causa
ucraniana soul y cuando se acaben las
existencias no se comprará más y se
apostará por otro tipo de licores esto
es christina un vodka ucraniano con el
que hemos trabajado desde hace años y
que siempre hemos tenido así es cómo
estos dos negocios con productos rusos
condenan una guerra que viven a
distancia pero sufren muy de cerca